the 40-year old TV presenter of love
island Caroline Flack has died her
family have announced the news a short
while ago let's bring in our
correspondent ash in a hurry nag to talk
about this some more this will come as
an enormous shock of course a well-loved
household name Caroline Flack but had
been in trouble in recent weeks and had
stood down from her position on love
island and was facing a trial in a few
weeks time absolutely we are hearing
these reports that Caroline Flack has
died the Sun newspaper does have a
family statement on their website and
that family statement on their website
says we can confirm that our Caroline
passed away today on the 15th of
February we would ask that the press
respect the privacy of this privacy of
this family at this difficult time as
you say she stepped down from presenting
love island back in december and after
that assault charged she's been a TV
host for years first appeared on both
selector' back in 2002 she's presented
several series of love Island and
x-factor also there will be lots of
questions this evening about what has
happened here about the treatment of the
presenter in the wake of this
controversy and particularly I suppose
there will be some focus on the program
love island given that two former
contestants mike Felicitas and sophie
graden took their lives in the wake of
being on that show there is some
indication if we look at her instagram
page of how she might have been feeling
around that sort of time of the charge
but also her feelings towards the show
when she stepped down from the show she
had a post up on Instagram saying that
they show had been her world and it was
the best show on television the last
time that she posted on her social media
Instagram page it was a picture of her
and her dog two days ago and before that
her last post was on the 24th of
December and where in some of the
comments in that in that Instagram post
on the 24th she made reference to the
fact that she's been advised to not go
on social media and she also said this
kind of scrutiny and speculation is a
lot to take on for one person to take
on their own okay I'm just gonna bring
that full statement that you were
referencing there I can bring you the
details of it the statement said we can
confirm that our Caroline passed away
today the 15th of February we would ask
that the press respect the privacy of
the family at this difficult time and we
would ask they make no attempt to
contact us and/or photograph us and that
is from the press Association and as you
might expect on social media the
tributes absolutely pouring in absolute
shock right across the board from all
sorts of people all colleagues indeed of
her Jameela Jamil one that just catching
mine out was only a matter of time
before the media and a prolonged social
media dogpile pushed someone over the
edge rest in peace Caroline Flack and I
can continue down the list Rebecca
Vaughn saying one show three deaths this
must stop I've been on the wrong side of
the effects of reality TV and people
don't understand how it can make you
want to die so there will be some very
difficult questions for ITV this evening
incredibly difficult conversations
people like Eamonn Holmes as well
Caroline Flack dear God shocked beyond
belief a real feeling that she was
somebody that is was incredibly loved
within the industry among in Instagram
but also loved Island stars as well
stars who when she stepped down from
that show they expressed their great
love of how she was a credibly warm
character for whenever they appeared on
the show with her she hosted that after
Sun show which after she filmed love
island over in Spain she would then come
over and then host this London show very
much an active part of that program but
also the x-factor as well so she will
have colleagues right across the media
industry who'll be paying tribute to her